people have told me to do this for a
very long time and I believe in destiny
and I believe not the game but in real
destiny and I believe that Klein and I
met for a reason and I know this for a
fact that if I hadn't met kalila I would
never do a podcast because she's the one
that got the equipment she's the one
that got George involved and you're
involved and this is all a part of the
the grand scheme of things okay so how
do you guys feel so far so good
I want to tell you about your careers
ending what about the your special
that's I'm going to do one yeah yes not
enough about me how are you doing doing
good IATA civics I'm in the CBS showcase
that's wonderful yeah so you I'm the
very but you when you're younger very
early on in my career
good things happen Gilbert I'm gonna say
this right now I don't know make fun of
you and I know I pretend I don't know
your name in public that's called you
feel even gay every ways yes what boy
the glasses at some points and but I
want to say this you would not be here
if you didn't have it thank you I was
mad about you for not going through that
you're mad to be audition with me you
could have got it if you just would have
just done it with me fun that's fine I
let it go but you you have the talent
you have the charisma and I'm so thank
you thanks man no thank you I'm really
angry at my niece why I need you guys
help
what'd she do oh okay so I have a niece
in the Philippines and I you know my
sister and I pay for no private
schooling we can't because I think that
she make up a name just for Morocco book
my real cousins name it's a boy well
that's a name quote unquote book yeah
his his real name is JR oh that's a
battle me but his real name is jr. jr.
called jr. nope this nickname
anyways no my other I have a niece my
sister and I pay for her schooling her
private schooling and it was her
birthday last week and
you know we both give her money on her
birthday we sent it over and this is the
second year in a row that she's
forgotten to say thank you and she's 15
now and I feel like I want to [ __ ]
just I its Jesus tell you know that you
hit that selfish stage when you're a
teenager your friends are everything and
your parents are nothing but I never
even in in in the sick of feeling that
way when I was a teenager I never forgot
to say thank you and I just feel so
betrayed by her and I want to tell her
like like where the [ __ ] are your
manners do you know how big a hundred
and fifty dollars is when you are a 15
year old in the Philippines that's a
lotta money I never got money when I was
a teenager
yeah ever and it's been a week and no
thank you
how her parents well dad what we're
gonna do about it I'm just so upset I
don't know if I should yell at her and
text her or just know we cut her off no
we cut her off no I would never cut off
her schooling are you kidding me that's
private school I would never do that my
sister and I are responsible for that
then don't complain if she hasn't said
thank you
no I this was a money for for her
birthday this wasn't money for school
was a gift
oh well then stop how about this you pay
for school yeah but no more gifts that's
good I think so man yeah yeah what she
done with gifts you hear me how are you
how are you guys raised were you with
your parents always force you to write
thank you cards or no see here's here's
okay I'm good I'm glad you said that
because here's the division the color I
find with kalila okay is is that I know
that I have to remember her birthday
like literally I have to remember it
yeah I have to remember when Christmases
mmm all right I still don't know what my
parents birthday is they don't know what
my birthday is they don't know what
Steve's birthday Steve is the only one
that kind of cares my brother so they
hey Dad it's my birthday next week can I
get you no good you know or whatever
your brother never forgets my birthday I
know he's always the only one that give
up gave a [ __ ] in my house all right so
when your birthday came up you know you
were like remember that one no we're
lazy
when's my birthday I got November 4th
right and then three days and then what
a week later I remember the rubber
burners I went on your Facebook
what are your girlfriend's face info
that's right and then I had I think
really get or anything that's not feel
bad about a part um but my point is is
that but you have to understand the way
I was with my parent my parents would
give me if i hate's my birthday how much
do you want I go $300
okay and give me cash and go buy
whatever I want to me I never opened it
my parents never wrapped anything so now
that date somebody you know I mean that
believes in it it's just it's it's
difficult I'm trying to figure it out
and I want to learn to do it yeah but if
I give you something you always say
thank you that's the point of it because
I started a movie thank you I remember I
saw in a movie somebody gave somebody a
gift and they said thank you and I just
spray ya thank ya what would you do to
say wait to the girl yeah just don't
give her anything from now on but then
you know I love her and I always want
her to wear just bring it up yeah I'm
just gonna have a talk with her mom just
be like dude you needa just manners yeah
remind her that thank yous are
everything thank you is our [ __ ]
currency in this world you know it goes
a very very long way
[Music]